we begin in afghanistan where several
people have been killed in a bomb blast
outside a well-known mosque the
explosion happened as mourners gathered
at the eidgar mosque complex for the
funeral of a senior taliban official's
mother taliban leaders were expected to
attend a nearby hospital says it's
treating four victims no one has so far
claimed responsibility
let's cross straight to kabul now dw
correspondent nick connolly is standing
by nick what more can you tell us about
this blast
well rebecca still a lot of confusion
over the actual
number of casualties
some sources saying just two civilian
casualties others uh being quoted as
naming that casualty um total at around
eight with more wounded this is really
about as downtown as it gets in kabul
just a few kilometers from where i am
now targeting as you mentioned there
high-ranking taliban official who's
responsible for press ironically he's
the very same man who used to claim
responsibility when the taliban carried
out attacks and now it is the memorial
service for his own mother that is being
targeted and predictably obviously the
um suspicion is falling on so-called
islamic state who have emerged in recent
weeks as
the taliban's main challenges here in
afghanistan
yeah there was also a shooting attack in
the eastern city of jalalabad this
weekend is afghanistan
poised for more violence after several
weeks of relative calm
[Music]
well indeed this was this attack here in
kabul today was the biggest and most
high profile attack since the attack on
kabul airport in august but those
attacks especially outside kabul never
really ended this was an attack on a
journalist they've been attacked on
taliban posts in that jalalabad region
which is known to be a particular hot
spot for circle islamic state in
afghanistan and for all the kind of
trouble messages from the taliban that
they are now well and truly in control
after 20 years fighting the americans
sending them home i think this is a lot
more precarious than they'd like us to
think um lots of um executions of
so-called kidnappers all across the
country um many of which are believed to
be in is militants so the situation that
is a lot less under control than they're
trying to portray and that isn't
properly
managed and you know simply the manpower
isn't there to make sure that that
control is spread across this huge
country
nick thank you dw's nick connolly
speaking to us from kabul